hey accidents happen but if you're in a
movie sometimes accidents can turn out
to be amazing in fact some of the most
memorable moments in cinema were
actually the result of mistakes that the
filmmakers decided were too good to
leave out of the finished movie here's a
look at some movie bloopers that were
too good to cut guardians of the galaxy
alfred hitchcock coined the term
macguffin to describe important objects
upon which the plot of a movie revolves
like the briefcase in pulp fiction or
the infinity stones in the marvel
cinematic universe as any comic fan will
tell you the infinity stones are
incredibly important and powerful which
is why it's so funny when chris pratt as
star-lord just straight up drops one let
us see what you brought
[Music]
it looks totally scripted but according
to the dvd commentary that was an actual
moment of clumsiness from pratt but the
moment works so director james gunn left
it in
the lord of the rings two towers as war
looms and the loss of rohan seems
imminent eowyn stares off into the
distance as the camera reveals a wide
scenic shot as she does a flagpole whips
in the wind and then perfectly
expressing the mood of uncertainty and
destruction to come the flag rips off
the pole and flies away
the metaphor was not only beautifully
apt but it was also totally accidental
director peter jackson didn't plan for
this it was just really windy on that
day of shooting the princess diaries
this movie made anne hathaway a star and
the dvd has become a slumber party
classic for little kids it's a classic
ugly duckling story of a girl named mia
who finds out she's the heir apparent to
a small european kingdom but she's so
very awkward you see falling down all
the time as she learns how to carry
herself with the grace and boys
befitting a royal at one point mia is
dancing on some bleachers in the rain at
a private school with a best friend
when she takes a pretty nasty tumble
[Laughter]
that's no stunt woman and that wasn't
supposed to happen hathaway really did
slip falling hard but it fit in so well
with the character's awkwardness that it
was kept in the finished film
casino royale the idea was simple one
girl rides a horse along the beach and
daniel craig swims up to her but as he
floated up the actor ran into a sandbank
giving him no choice but to quickly
stand up on his feet and stomp out of
the water suddenly bondi standing there
muscled up body on display along with
some very revealing swim trunks casino
royale was a reboot of the bond series
so most fans assumed this was an homage
to the classic scene from the first bond
film dr no where ursula andres emerges
from the ocean but it was actually just
a lucky accident
raiders of the lost ark
indiana jones wasn't the only raider of
the lost ark in uh raiders of the lost
ark there was also evil french
archaeologist renee bellock who suffers
a doubly horrible fate not only does his
head explode
but he also needs a fly well okay not
exactly during a close-up of actor paul
freeman a fly appears to crawl right
down bellock's throat freeman later
revealed that the insect actually flew
away after crawling around his lip for a
moment but some judicious editing after
the fact made it look like the
cold-blooded belloc just ate the fly
instead
the usual suspects the police lineup
seen early in the movie is crucial to
the plot of the usual suspects it's
where all the criminal main characters
meet to arrange a big heist as each
character steps forward to read the line
police told them to read none of them
can contain their laughter perfectly
setting up the dynamic between the
characters as well as their collective
disregard for the cops
[Laughter]
but the laughing wasn't in the script
and it wasn't a directorial note no the
cast of the usual suspects couldn't stop
laughing because actor benicio del toro
couldn't stop farting co-star kevin
pollock says he farted on like 12 takes
in a row director brian singer got so
mad with the cast's inability to focus
that he yelled at them which probably
only made them laugh harder
rain man
speaking of farts rain man is that rare
film that won the oscar for best picture
and also included one of the most
memorable fart scenes in movie history
brothers raymond and charlie are in a
phone booth together and raymond passes
gas
oh [ __ ]
yeah charlie babbitt i'll hold hard
did you fart right
how can you stand there i don't mind
that was real and accidental
stars dustin hoffman and tom cruise both
managed to stay completely in character
setting up a classic moment in cinematic
fart history
chris hemsworth is one of those rare
actors who can do it all the australian
star clearly excels in action films
considering he's the mighty thor of the
avengers in the marvel cinematic
universe but he can also handle fantasy
comedy drama and even horror this kind
of versatility means that hemsworth is
regularly on set and all those long
hours can even make the biggest movie
stars a little loopy well the results
have been caught on film here are some
of the best chris hemsworth bloopers
juggling act
mjolnir thor's mighty hammer is
unmovable by pretty much everyone except
the god of thunder himself it's probably
the most famous object in norse
mythology and certainly the most famous
tool in comics this side of captain
america's shield or batman's utility
belt of course the hammer hemsworth
carries around in all the marvel films
is just a lightweight prop and
apparently he can toss it around and
juggle it quite easily okay maybe not
easily
[Music]
joke busters before the cameras roll
actors carefully memorize their lines
preparation is important for a good
performance of course but
familiarization with material is
critical in comedies if actors don't
know what's coming they're liable to
laugh and ruin takes now imagine how
tricky it gets once everyone is
improvising on the spot take the 2016
ghostbusters for example when hemsworth
had to describe why he likes hot dogs
contains all two food groups
[Music]
dogs and buns
[Music]
director paul feig encourages actors to
try out ideas that pop into their heads
during filming and even throws out
suggestions himself but sometimes when a
joke is brand new it's hard to deliver
with a straight face i slept through a
fire once
i didn't even smell it
it was in your house yeah
i was burned down around me
and once a bad case of the giggles has
set in there may be no coming back from
it fire was in your house
yeah
and the whole house went down
just say it
certain scenes in thor the dark world
between hemsworth and natalie portman's
character jane foster are tender and
emotionally powerful well they were
supposed to be
but i do know this
know what i know that
that what
come on thor just tell her how you feel
saying i don't know
what happened where you were
huntsman holdups
hemsworth plays the title role in the
huntsman films the action-packed
adaptations of the snow white folktale
collected and popularized by the
brothers grimm in 19th century germany
the films actually take place long
before that they have a strong medieval
fairy tale vibe at any rate it's long
before the dawn of mechanical flight
which means hemsworth had to put the
acting on pause whenever filming was
interrupted by scene-stealing airplanes
the planes weren't the only things that
held up production unfortunately there
was one onset diva who wanted nothing to
do with poor hemsworth
[Music]
and then there was those moments where
he had no one to blame but himself
fam
the worst piece of acting ever
do a little dance what if you witnessed
one of the strongest and most
unbreakable objects on the planet crack
in half and reveal itself for what it
truly is some flimsy little objects
glued together let's just say a little
dancing solves most problems
[Music]
keep going wild the three most defining
characteristics of thor are the powerful
hammer in his hand had long blonde hair
and his red cape that ripples in the
wind behind him well two out of three
ain't bad because on the set of this
standalone thor film hemsworth's most
temperamental co-star was that cape
in addition to the cape issues on the
dark world set it apparently wasn't
clear to some people whether certain
scenes had finished filming or not i
believe you were and you weren't
[Laughter]
dwayne the rock johnson can kinda do it
all successfully transitioning from a
career as one of the most popular and
accomplished wrestling stars of all time
he's gone on to a hollywood career that
spanned everything from action flicks
like the fast and furious franchise to
family films like the tooth fairy to
comedies like central intelligence
johnson is a likable guy who always
seems happy to be wherever he is and he
never takes himself too seriously
particularly on movie sets here's a look
at some bloopers that make us love the
rock even more
walking tall
johnson is tough the kind of guy who
could easily smash things without the
need for special props or stuntmen to do
the dirty work for him at least one
would think that would be the case when
the wrestler was cast in one of his
first major lead roles as chris vaughn
jr in the 2004 remake of the 70s classic
walking tall he discovered that his
toughest enemy wasn't the bad guy at all
but rather a particularly obstinate car
tail light
i'm strong i swear
journey to the mysterious island a not
so little-known fact about dwayne the
rock johnson dude is seriously jacked
his muscles are absurdly large so on the
set of journey 2 the mysterious island
he decided to let his body do the
talking instead of his mouth it's a
hilarious effect
what is this
[Music]
the game plan
it's almost like johnson went full
method actor with this blooper in the
game plan he plays a star quarterback
who's thrust into the wackiness of
fatherhood upon suddenly learning he has
an eight-year-old daughter but as it
turns out there are certain pitfalls
involved in having a tea party when
you're as massive as the rock
small chair big guy
classic
the other guys
it looks like johnson had cold feet when
it came time to film this big scene in
the cop comedy the other guys in which
she briefly co-starred opposite samuel l
jackson the two extra awesome detectives
end up jumping off a building at least
they're supposed to
central intelligence
in this clip johnson shows he's not too
tough to take a little ribbing after he
admits to the character played by
comedian kevin hart that his name is
made up hart gives him a pep talk
arguing that having a made-up name isn't
such a big deal heart then rattles off a
bunch of cool names that everybody knows
aren't real including someone very
familiar to johnson you think uh mr t
and and sting and and the rock you think
those guys are real that's a bunch of
dumbass nicknames by a bunch of dumbass
people
the tooth fairy
well there's a magazine for everything
and everyone even tooth fairies in this
blooper from the set of the family
friendly comedy the tooth fairy in which
johnson plays against type as a tooth
fairy he shows that he's still a man a
man with needs
race to witch mountain johnson keeps the
mood light and shows that he has some
pretty agile improv comedy skills for a
guy best known for big and flashy action
movies during the filming of this disney
remake johnson yells out the names of a
bunch of different animals in an attempt
to distract another character including
one very dangerous animal in particular
is that a woodchuck ferret kangaroo
then diesel
guy's better looking
fast five
speaking of vin diesel here's johnson
messing around on the set of fast five
he's only pretending to mercilessly
pummel vin diesel about the head and
face over and over again though
according to internet rumor he probably
wishes he had unloaded for real when he
had the chance
you can't make a great horror movie
without also making a few mistakes the
final girl bursts out laughing during a
big escape scene the blood spewing
machine malfunctions and saturates the
entire set the flesh-eating swamp
monster trips over his own tentacles and
falls down a flight of stairs sometimes
these clips get relegated to the gag
reel while in other cases they're so
good they end up in the final film
either way here's a look at some great
bloopers that will change the way you
see these horror movies
the cabin in the woods josh whedon's
2012 entry into the horror genre was
typically tongue-in-cheek filled with
intentional hilarious subversions of
various scary movie tropes including the
epic finale in which a virtual
encyclopedia of monsters escape from
their cells and annihilate the
technicians who have been holding them
captive but while the carnage of that
last act was planned one of its best
scenes was the beneficiary of a happy
little accident specifically we're
talking about the scene where actor
bradley whitford was eaten by the merman
the death itself was cool but the best
part is what comes after
oh come on
the blowhole shooting blood is hilarious
but it's also not what the filmmakers
originally planned with only the one
scene to shoot the effects crew decided
to use their entire remaining supply of
fake blood so instead of a little burp
of blood the merman blew like old
faithful and kept on blowing until the
blood ran out and the geyser-like effect
was replaced by a
farty red mist effects master david lee
roy anderson of afx later said i love
the wide shot in the behind the scenes
video where the blood keeps going and
going because it reminds me of that
night which was just hysterical i kept
thinking how are they going to use this
he's sitting there flapping like a fish
and it looks like a hose spraying blood
everywhere but the way they cut it
together was perfect
scream
in 1996 where's craven send up of the
slasher genre heralded the dawn of a new
wave of smart sleek self-aware horror
films the special effects however were
the same tried and true practical
techniques directors have relied on for
years including the use of corn syrup to
simulate blood and in a movie where it
seemed like someone was stabbed to death
every other minute things were extremely
sloppy and sticky on set by the time the
film reached its thrilling climax this
led to a hilarious unplanned exchange
when skeet ulrich lost control of the
blood-covered phone and accidentally
winged it right at matthew lillard's
head leading to a very genuine reaction
from the surprised actor
[Music]
ordinarily an outburst like that might
have led to a shout of cut and a request
to do the scene again but according to
the scream dvd commentary because
lillard was supposed to be playing the
doofy sidekick to ulrich's cold-blooded
psychopath his reaction wasn't out of
character craven went ahead and kept it
safely off the cutting room floor as it
turned out it was a wise move not only
did the line make it to the final cut
it's one of the funniest moments in the
movie another of the funniest moments in
scream can only be seen in the blooper
reel though and it comes courtesy of the
director himself where's craven who also
directed the classic nightmare on elm
street made a cameo in scream dressed as
nightmare villain freddy krueger that
was fun enough but in one outtake he
demonstrated a gift for physical comedy
that fans wish had made the final film
[Applause]
scream three the third entry in the
scream franchise was also improved by an
on-camera mistake the exciting
conclusion to wes craven's scream
trilogy is full of scripted suspense but
one of its most action-packed fight
scenes has a big blooper right in the
middle according to an encyclopedia
collection of scream 3 trivia the
confrontation between nev campbell and
scott foley includes an actual genuine
stabbing in the moment where sydney
leaps over a bar and nails roman in the
back with an ice pick
foley was wearing a protective pad for
the scene but campbell missed her mark
and plunged the pick into foley's actual
flesh no wonder his scream of surprise
and pain seems so genuine
the descent
a terrifying movie in which a bunch of
young women are stalked and killed while
exploring a darkened cave system it gets
even more frightening when the descent
adds in a bunch of subterranean monsters
wanting to eat their delicious flesh but
that's why it's so funny on the blooper
reel when one of the victims whose face
is all deformed from unspeakable things
gives one of the humans an unexpected
moment of romance
[Music]
house of wax the 2005 remake of the 50s
horror classic house of wax starred wb
heartthrobs such as chad michael murray
from one tree hill jared padalecki from
gilmore girls and the socialite reality
star and the night vision camera owner
paris hilton to her credit the often
dispassionate hilton gives everything
she's got to her performance as a scream
queen shrieking bloody murder as the
script requires the screaming is
intentionally annoying but still not
nearly as annoying as the actual car
alarm that went off during a scene in
the woods ruining the shot
scream 4 acting can be magical when a
director gets a perfect believable
reaction from a performer like one of
abject terror in a horror movie for
example or you can just pull a prank on
an actor on a set of a horror movie and
scare him for real on the set of scream
four eric nudeson was apparently
supposed to open a door and find nothing
there instead of nothing however there
was something something actually pretty
frightening
especially if you're not expecting it
halloween
star malcolm mcdowell is always an
imposing presence who dominates every
scene he's in whether he's playing the
hero an anti-hero or a villain in rob
zombie's 2007 version of halloween he
plays dr samuel loomis the former
psychiatrist of crazed murderer michael
myers myers eventually comes for dr
loomis of course and he cowers in fear
in a darkened house but when myers
smashes through the door to get him
mcdowell seems taken off guard
apparently he didn't realize they were
filming that bit yet
you must be
joking
that halloween reboot must have been a
pretty lively set to work on because its
blooper reel offers up another goofy
outtake what's so funny about being
stabbed as far as actor ken forrey is
concerned everything while michael myers
repeatedly stabs him with a prop knife
and fake blood audibly oozes everywhere
4a gets a case of the giggles that
simply won't die
jennifer's body oscar winner diablo cody
wrote the screenplay for jennifer's body
which offered character relationships a
bit more complex than those in the
average horror movie over the course of
the film nerdy anita played by amanda
seyfried comes to both love and hate her
best friend popular cheerleader turned
murderer succubus jennifer played by
megan fox those mixed feelings
physically manifest in a scene in which
sci-fred screams accusatory things that
[ __ ] his character and then kisses her
or at least she tries to kiss her as fox
is apparently so deep in her monstrous
character that she takes a bite out of
her coaster
i actually bit her i'm sorry
the witch one of the most truly haunting
horror movies in years was the witch it
features an atmospheric setting in
colonial massachusetts and it's paired
with the scary premise that the witches
of the salem wits trial era just might
have been real there's a ton of weird
stuff in the witch from dark woods to
kidnapping to naked people drinking
blood to a goat named black philip that
a pair of creepy twins says talks to
them yeah but what's not so scary though
horses particularly horses needing to go
about their horse bodily functions with
no regard for the very expensive film
production happening right in front of
them
if you don't let me along with you i'll
awake mother m father this instant
the silence of the lambs anthony hopkins
deservedly won an academy award for best
actor for his performance as
cannibalistic serial killer hannibal
lecter in the silence of the lamps
famously it was one of only a handful of
horror movies to ever take home major
oscars hopkins is one of the best actors
in the world and as such is quite
versatile he played an american
president in nixon and a repressed
english butler in the remains of the day
he even played rocky balboa once no
really he did well his face and shirt
were covered in blood during a twisted
and hilarious outtake on the set of the
silence of the lambs he brought his
inner rocky out for the world to say
this one is for you adrian
are you paulie
let's go for it
rocky five
let's do it now guy goes on the box even
cannibals need to laugh now and then
shawn of the dead zombie driven horror
comedy sean of the dead made a movie
star out of simon pegg it's also
reunited the actor with his
collaborators from the cult of british
sitcom spaced including director edgar
wright and co-star nick frost they're
all good friends and seem to share the
same comedy hive mind which means peg
and frost are frequently ad-libbed and
goofed off on the set of shaun of the
dead ruining takes but cracking up each
other and anybody else in the vicinity
over here over here oh bollocks okay
just just just snitches
now why don't rick and the rest of the
gang on walking dead destroy that next
time
kaylee cuoco was a seasoned screen
veteran long before she started working
his penny on the big bang theory but
even she isn't immune to the odd flub on
the set every now and then here's a look
at some of the funniest goofs from a
very funny career
let's get popping
in a 9th season episode of the big bang
theory jim parsons sheldon makes a video
for crazy future sheldon and starts the
explanatory video for himself with some
footage of penny who in this outtake is
just way too busy with her popcorn to
care
in another take the camera stays on
sheldon who makes a wise crack about
penny penny and her popcorn however
aren't having it she offers you food
it's safe to take it you probably paid
for it anyway
oh hi
as the script in this season 3 episode
was written quoco's penny reacts to a
comment from simon hellberg's howard by
sarcastically asking are you high at
first it's co-star johnny galecki who
flubs his follow-up line are you high
you'd have a brenda mcdonald
english the director resets the scene
and gives instructions on where to start
over but cuoco's still concerned about
galecki
are you high
still that's not the end
my point is i do not judge a book by but
hi
[Applause]
doing it wrong
the big bang theory characters hold the
star trek franchise in high esteem
throughout the series one would think
that all of that star trek stuff
constantly on the set would have forced
its way into kaylie cuoco's brain but
that's clearly not the case at least
when she's supposed to be giving spock's
famous vulcan salute i am spock
[Music]
[Applause]
another word for leonard in this blooper
kaylee cuoco stumbles over a word she
probably has to say more than any other
in the line of duty leonard the name of
her character's neighbor then boyfriend
then husband
leonard leonard
leonard balls
cuoco's blooper then grows infectious as
co-star jim parsons can't get through
the next part of the scene without
fudging his own dialogue
uh gripping mur go no
balls the key word is balls
not very appetizing in the early seasons
of the big bang theory penny makes ends
meet waitressing at the cheesecake
factory while pursuing her dreams of
being an actress to save money she
subsequently exploits her proximity to
the guys by helping herself to their
food as well as their wifi in this fifth
season episode penny casually enters the
guy's apartment to get the new wi-fi
password but doesn't seem to understand
what one actually does with wi-fi
okay if you can't get me to stop eating
your food but make sure you get me to
stop eating your
wi-fi just a little teasing
the abc sitcom eight simple rules for
dating my teenage daughter was kaylee
cuoco's first major role on a successful
show she portrayed the slightly
rebellious and independent daughter of
beloved tv icon john ritter the kid vs
adult struggle at the center of the show
becomes comically real in this blooper
from the first season
action
yes you can rip kaylie cuoco on a sitcom
set but she can give as good as she gets
even to a legend like john ritter on the
set of eight simple rules cuoco can't
really start her scene until ritter
walks onto the stage and boy is she
impatient
along with behind the scenes features
and the occasional marvel one shot the
gag reels are a favorite staple of
marvel blu-ray releases fans not only
get to laugh but we also see the bonds
formed behind the scenes and it's hard
not to fall in love with them just a
little bit here are some of the most
hilarious bloopers and gags waiting on
the thor ragnarok blu-ray
butterfingers
one of milner's amazing properties is
that when thor wills it back to his hand
it comes straight away even if the
hammer needs to cross nations galaxies
or dr strange's entire collection of
sorcerer artifacts mjolnir always comes
home
sorry unfortunately mjolnir's fantastic
abilities are one thing and the
properties of thor ragnarok's props are
another the blu-rays gag reel proves
that either someone off camera wasn't
very good at throwing or the cast just
isn't very good at catching
this kind of thing is to be expected by
all appearances chris hemsworth has
never been able to catch anything anyway
low blows
thor ragnarok included some fantastic
leading female characters cate blanchett
turned in a fun and utterly vicious
portrayal of the lead villain and tessa
thompson was funny believable and badass
as valkyrie
he's mine
[Music]
and that just makes the number of crotch
shots that happen during filming even
more fitting especially since almost all
of them come unintentionally from
blanchett thompson or thompson stunt
double
[Music]
you may be familiar with the story that
while filming lightsaber duels in the
star wars prequels even mcgregor had to
make an effort not to make his own
lightsaber sounds to begin with it was
quite difficult not to make the sound
yeah
and also when it goes away because it
makes that nice
noise when it goes down well apparently
it's not as uncommon as you'd think the
ragnarok gag reel shows us a number of
shots when cate blanchett had to stop
because she realized she was making
comic book sound effects
do i should make the noises with my
mouth today
warm up not everything on the gag reel
is a blooper sometimes perfectly
reasonable things like warming up
between takes just looks funny
hey they're not playing to the camera or
making any funny mistakes they're just
making sure they don't pull a hamstring
when they pretend to be super people for
a couple of minutes no harm in that
all fall down maybe it's a side effect
of the revenger's escape from sakhar
through the devil's anus or maybe
director taika waititi took the
bottomless mug of beer from the doctor
strange scene and passed it around the
cast and crew every day but for whatever
reason no one in the cast of thor
ragnarok seemed to be able to stay
upright for more than a few seconds at a
time
[Music]
what makes their various spills that
much funnier is that it never seems like
there's anything in particular knocking
them down they don't seem to be in the
middle of complicated action sequences
they just fall down
a lot
[Music]
avenging bros
while chris hemsworth and mark ruffalo
don't have the same chemistry going as
iron man and hulk did in the avengers
they've got their own buddy feel in thor
ragnarok though it's definitely more odd
couple i smashed you yeah sure sure baby
arms what babies
[Music]
almost two years before the film's
release mark ruffalo compared the thor
hulk relationship in ragnarok to the one
between robert de niro and charles
grodin in 1988's midnight run it's a
love-hate relationship but the two still
share some hilarious moments in the gag
reel i thought you were gone forever i'm
glad to see you man
he wrote him on the sky
unique skill the grand master of the
comics isn't a particularly fun guy
unless you think fun is to habitually
kidnap superheroes to make them fight
for your amusement regardless jeff
goldblum's realization of the character
is one of the best reasons to see
ragnarok
you're officially pardoned
from life
[Music]
and when he shows up in the gag reel he
definitely leaves an impression most
notably when he demonstrates his real
life superpower watch this
[Music]
dancing fools
most of the marvel gag reels feature
bits of the cast breaking into dance
while filming and the reel for thor
ragnarok is no exception but while the
cast occasionally cut a rug the fanciest
feat on the set undoubtedly belonged to
director taika waititi who apparently
never stops dancing a day on the set
working with taika involves hijinks
dancing yeah he's just a big kid in the
end all that play time translated into
an incredibly fun movie so maybe taika
ytt is onto something that is how you
make movies
after first finding american fame and
the goofy 90s sitcom two guys a girl in
a pizza place ryan reynolds moved on to
play leading roles in multiple romantic
comedies as well as action flicks like
blade trinity green lantern and of
course deadpool the role he was born to
play reynolds always brings a playful
edge and a sharp sense of humor to his
roles which can lead to a lot of extra
footage and hilarious outtakes here are
some of ryan reynolds best bloopers
deadpool
with deadpool hollywood finally figured
out what to do with ryan reynolds the
fictional character blended so
seamlessly with reynold's real-life
sense of humor that the movie relied
heavily on reynolds improvisation it's
very nice to see you
schwarzenegger however only one take of
a scene can make the final cut meaning
there's a lot of deadpool outtake
footage before wade wilson becomes
deadpool he submits to some highly
questionable medical experimentation he
keeps his spirits up by making fun of
his captors which gives reynolds a
chance to rattle off different insults
you're gonna leave me all alone here
with henry winkler you know leave me all
alone here with hey you guys you're
gonna leave me all alone here with chris
angel mind freak then there's this scene
where deadpool shows up at the x-men
mansion and talks about the joys of
joining the team yeah that's right i
can't wait to
to join the gang can't wait to give the
beast a nice little belly rub it's gonna
be great
blade trinity
what few comic moments there are in the
dark and violent conclusion to wesley
snipes vampire hunter trilogy come
courtesy of ryan reynolds even though
blade himself ignores most of those
jokes in this blooper director david s
goyer let reynolds riff in character
describing his character's musical
tastes in the process it's me
i'm more of a kenny g fan myself you
know early stuff though before he sold
out
me
i'm more of a clay aiken fan
people say i look like him
me
i'm more of a don johnson fan a lot of
people don't know he recorded an album
the proposal
this 2009 rom-com starred three of
hollywood's most well-liked actors
sandra bullock betty white and ryan
reynolds in one of the scenes they all
get together for a group hug which leads
to one of the best bloopers from the
[Music]
my movie she's got my nipple
honestly we can't tell if reynolds is
making fun of betty white's height or if
white actually tried to take a bite out
of him either way at least they didn't
start kissing nope reynolds saved all
that loving for the dog
[Music]
the hitman's bodyguard
regardless of your religion nuns are
generally regarded as people you don't
mess with so of course that's what ryan
reynolds does in one scene for the
hitman's bodyguard reynolds is in a bus
with a bunch of clapping nuns he waits
for a quiet moment and launches a clap
attack on the one sitting right next to
him
the change up
in this blooper from the body switch
movie the changeup reynolds reacts
quickly when he can't remember his lines
he stays in character as long as he can
before admitting to co-star jason
bateman that he has no idea what he's
supposed to be doing i don't feel
particularly good about this
we're just doing a pickup no i i just uh
had a complete brain malfunction
you want to reload probably because i
don't feel particularly good about this
just friends
let's face it poop jokes can be pretty
funny they're even funny on repeat
possibly even funnier case in point this
blooper from the comedy just friends
each time reynolds tries to say his
ridiculous line he and co-star amy smart
just laugh harder and harder leave why
would mr pee-pee pants want to leave
stick around
myself
stick around i'm going to crack my pants
i'm going to grab my nails
ripd
it's nice to know that some actors never
lose their sense of fun while filming a
movie as this footage from the making of
ripv shows reynolds always has a blast
while making a film of course it helps
that he's got some fellow goofballs like
jeff bridges and kevin bacon to play
against and a stunt car to mess around
in
tell her i made some good investments
there's something undeniably
entertaining about watching actors mess
up a scene by flubbing a line breaking
character or even walking into a wall
these classic movie bloopers are just as
entertaining as the films they came from
in fact in some cases they're even
better and they've kept us cracking up
for years
smokey and the bandit too
more than 35 years after the release of
smoky and the bandit 2 many comedies
still run a blooper reel over the
closing credits and from bandit's
credits it's clear that stars bert
reynolds and sally field had a blast
working on the film when we get started
it's my life you say whenever whenever
you like whenever you like
so i keep it rolling this is good stuff
yeah i like this sadly in the years
since a credits blooper reel has
actually become a pretty reliable
indicator that the movie itself isn't
all that funny
you're wrong
home alone
unless you're some kind of monster
there's not much that's funny about
watching a child get hurt but when
macaulay culkin slips on ice on an
outtake from the first home alone film
well it's downright hilarious
perhaps it's because falling down is
always funny no matter who's doing the
falling
north by northwest
in one of alfred hitchcock's best films
north by north west eva marie saint's
character pulls out a gun in a crowded
cafeteria as suspenseful as it is
viewers who pay close attention will
know ahead of time that she's going to
fire that gun that's all thanks to a
little boy in the background who plugs
his ears five seconds too early
are you little fool just stay away from
me
back to the future
in this classic time travel comedy
michael j fox's character marty takes
her swig from a bottle of booze while on
a date with lorraine played by leah
thompson to his surprise some back to
the future associates decided to help
him out by filling it with actual liquor
his reaction was 100 real and he didn't
seem too upset about it either
the frighteners
before he moved on to epic films like
the lord of the rings and king kong
peter jackson directed this quirky
horror movie about a guy who develops
the ability to communicate with ghosts
though michael j fox wanted audiences to
associate him with something other than
back to the future it seems that even he
had a hard time doing that himself
during the shoot when speaking to the
character named the judge foxx kept
calling him dark as in dark brown from
back to the future
little cooking the pony express huh doc
whoa
i call them darkness
[Music]
duck
duck i did it again
we are the millers
jason sedakis jennifer aniston emma
roberts and will poulter pretend to be a
family as part of a drug smuggling
operation and we're the millers in one
scene tadakis's character turns on a
radio and tlc's waterfalls are supposed
to play instead the cast and crew took
this opportunity to prank aniston by
blasting the theme from friends instead
[Music]
aniston's emotional reaction made it
totally worth it
liar
liar
jim curry is an incredible improviser
and directors will often just keep the
cameras rolling and let him experiment
liar liar is one of carrie's most
over-the-top comedic performances and
while the filmmakers couldn't use all of
his hilarious improv in the film they
created a gag reel to play over the
credits
[Music]
it's also quite a treat to watch cast
members clap back at him with hilarious
moments of their own your honor i have
checked you would over act
star trek
one thing unites the many star trek
properties from the original series in
the 1960s to the world expanding shows
in the 80s and 90s to the big budget
film reboots of the 21st century
spaceship doors never seem to work
correctly
for generations these characters just
can't seem to exit a room very important
raiders of the lost ark the classic
indiana jones flick raiders of the lost
ark is a film with a mistake that
actually made it into the final cut and
it's kind of a gross one so of course we
can't look away in an extreme close-up
on actor paul freeman the camera
captures a fly landing on his face and
crawling right into his mouth
your persistence surprises even me
you're gonna give mercenaries a bad name
in an interview with fans like the indie
experience freeman claims that the fly
never actually went into his mouth but
that an editor played around with frames
to make it look like it did the effect
is gross enough that there's really one
appropriate reaction
meanwhile another beloved movie has a
blooper that made its way into the final
cut and is now as cherished a part of
the movie as any of its other pets
star wars
probably because it's part of one of the
most successful and beloved movies of
all time the stormtrooper bonking his
head on the doorframe during star wars
as one of the most famous movie bloopers
ever and it never gets old
[Music]
it's a rare and welcome bit of physical
comedy in the otherwise dramatic space
opera plus with stormtroopers constantly
getting themselves shot blown up and
thrown around this minor mishap really
helps drive home the idea that these
faceless soldiers are the imperial
keystone cops of outer space
movie bloopers are a lot of fun plain
and simple film fans love to watch
actors flub and considering the way they
make themselves and their co-stars laugh
when it happens actors clearly love
bloopers too filmmakers on the other
hand may not love them quite as much
every time an actor makes a mistake it
delays the shoot just a little and time
is money and every so often they're
forced to deal with a truly world-class
mess up a mistake that cost the
production big money due to property
damage and personal injury
7. brad pitt suffered a nasty injury on
the set of seven during one scene they
called for him to chase his suspect in
the rain he slipped and smashed his hand
into a windshield severing a tendon
director david fincher mentions on the
film's dvd commentary that pitch showed
him his wound which was so severe he
could see the white of the bone making
the best of a bad situation fincher
managed to incorporate pitt's injury
into the story of seven by having the
script rewritten to have pitt's
characters suffer an injury in the line
of duty it added time and expense to the
production schedule but it was probably
a lot cheaper to explain why one of the
film's main characters was suddenly
wearing a cast than simply delaying
shooting long enough for pitt to recover
still it didn't solve the problem
completely like most movies 7 was shot
out of sequence so an earlier scene
filmed after pitt's injury required the
actor to hold his bad hand in his pocket
or behind his back
skyfall
according to writer and filmmaker
charlie line the 2012 james bond
adventure skyfall had to deal with some
unplanned expenses because star daniel
craig wore a pair of leather gloves at
the wrong moment as lion told a story
via twitter which he heard from someone
who worked on the film craig asked
director sam mendes if he could wear a
pair of leather gloves in a particular
scene mendez agreed and the cast and
crew got down to work filming a sequence
in which a bad guy gets bond's gun away
from him only to find he can't fire it
because it has a fingerprint scanner it
will only work for bond there's a
microdermal sensor than the grip
it's been coated to your palm print so
only you can fire it months later in the
editing bay a production assistant
noticed a problem then how was bond ever
gonna fire it wearing gloves
and so silence falls across the room
after considering the cost of reshooting
the scene the filmmakers decided it
would be cheaper although still quite
expensive to digitally remove the gloves
from craig's hands for the entire
sequence if you watch the scene now
honest to god you can see that bond has
these ridiculously
pudgy hands he has these like mr blobby
hands because in every single frame he
was wearing these thick leather gloves
that have now been painted over
with craig tone hands
the hateful eight
to play the crafty outlaw daisy darmagu
and quentin tarantino's the hateful
eight jennifer jason lee had to learn
how to play the guitar the lucky actress
got to learn on the same one she'd strum
in the film a vintage martin guitar
dating to the 19th century loaned to the
movie by the martin guitar museum lee's
big guitar playing moment on screen was
all planned out while she was playing
co-star kurt russell was supposed to
grab it the scene would cut and the
martin would be traded out for a cheaper
prop guitar which russell would smash
when the camera started to roll again
but that isn't what happened instead
russell grabbed the real martin from lee
and smashed it give me that guitar
music time's over
lee later told billboard kurt felt
terrible he had no idea
justice league
sometimes it's not the actor who goofs
up it's the studio responsible for the
movie and then they have to fork out the
cash to make things right warner
brothers had to reassemble the cast of
justice league in the summer of 2017 for
some crucial reshoots henry cavill who
plays superman was among those summoned
but there was a problem he'd grown a
mustache for his next role in the sixth
mission impossible movie and was
contractually obligated to keep it until
mi6 was finished filming the facial hair
scheduling snafu left justice league's
visual effects technicians with the job
of digitally removing superman's
mustache effects expert dave fleet told
business insider it could cost millions
we would need to build a 3d model of the
face and then shade the surface of the
skin to look realistic we would then
need to track the 3d model to the
movement of his head and potentially
reanimate his mouth that mustache has
got to go
it makes you look like a turtle
it makes you look like a total piggy
the avengers
marvel's superhero team isn't the only
avengers in pop culture there's also the
avengers a 1960s british spy tv series
the 1998 film adaptation starring ray
fines and uma thurman was a critical and
commercial bomb but the movie made
headlines for another type of detonation
while the crew filmed an explosion for
the movie a few rogue sparks drifted
away and hit the roof of the studio
starting a fire that was definitely not
part of the plan a set worth a reported
1.6 million dollars was destroyed along
with the hopes of any sequel never trust
the weather so august
rain or shine
all is might
the bloopers from the avengers films
might be some of the funniest we've seen
in a while in fact they're so funny that
it's hard not to fall in love with the
films all over again
in the realm of superheroes especially
norse mythology derived superheroes
you're only as good as your accessories
thor has quite a few his long red cape
his long blonde hair and his mighty
hammer mjolnir when it comes to his
hammer it's so tough and unbreakable
that it took the might of hella the
goddess of death to finally break it in
thor ragnarok maybe they got the idea
for that moment from this blooper in
which thor's magical hammer sure seems
like a very breakable prop
one of the few things as iconic as
thor's hammer in the mcu is captain
america's shield it's about as classic
as superhero equipment gets and it's so
powerful that cap routinely busts
through walls and locks with it
unfortunately the real prop shield they
use in the filming is a lot less useful
than its fictional counterpart
[Music]
it's easy for the comic book version of
bruce banner to just rattle off
scientific terms because someone can
just scribble them into a speech bubble
it's clearly a bit harder for actors to
say all those complicated words in real
life just watch mark ruffalo as he
struggles to deliver what's clearly a
mouthful of technical mumbo-jumbo in the
avengers age of ultron
pluripotent cells inside a xylo
pluripotent cells into a xylon secular
in a deleted scene in iron man 3 trevor
slatterly successfully passes himself
off as a russian over the phone which
leads to colonel james rhodes asking him
to try out a number of other voices it's
really just a chance for academy
award-winning actor sir ben kingsley to
display his acting ability and dialect
talent because he can handle every
suggestion actor don cheadle throws his
way the jamaican guy i come from jamaica
hey can you do french hello
can you do like a spanish
i can do but shut up
well almost every suggestion can you do
uh british
well i'm british
when bruce banner turns into the hulk to
punch a giant alien in the avengers is a
stand up and clap moment however as it
turns out that wasn't exactly the first
instinct that actor mark ruffalo had
when facing down a cgi monstrosity
[Music]
considering how terrifying the aliens
looked on the big screen it's hard to
fault ruffalo's acting instincts
paul bettany used to just provide the
voice of jarvis in the marvel cinematic
universe but these days he's using his
whole self to play vision betany is
barely recognizable under all that red
makeup while he certainly looks the part
of the super advanced robot he's acting
more like a malfunctioning computer in
this blooper from captain america civil
war it's maximum
miss maximoff manipulates molecular
polarity
one of the most impressive things about
the mcu is that the actors are able to
take it all seriously when surrounded by
goofy costumes and cgi monsters it's the
kind of true commitment to character
that explains why they get paid so much
however that doesn't mean there aren't a
few moments where that seriousness cuts
out in this lineup of stern determined
looking heroes for avengers infinity war
benedict wong just couldn't keep the
steely resolve in his face for more than
a few seconds
spider-man homecoming included one of
the most memorable cameos in mcu history
when chris evans's captain america pops
in via green screened video to deliver
some corny educational advice to the
students of peters high school
so
you got detention
you screwed up
however one particular video is just a
bit too over the top for evans to make
it through without cracking up hi i'm
captain america whether you're a student
or a soldier there's one thing that will
always give you an edge
a hot lunch
ant-man and the wasp was packed with
plenty of car chases through san
francisco a city full of steep hills big
curves and tons of traffic in this
blooper paul rudd gets into character as
he prepares to shoot one of those
sequences contain everyone let's have a
look at this one best thing in the movie
is it bad if i start the single like
this
an mcu movie made in the last few years
just wouldn't be complete without a stan
lee appearance and ant-man and the wasp
had one of the legendary creators best
cameos as scott lang hope van dyne and
their associates battle bad guys through
the twisty streets of san francisco lee
shows up as a guy whose car gets shrunk
by ant-man's signature technology
well the 60s were fun but now i'm paying
for it
it turns out that's just the take
filmmakers decided on they had lee go
through a huge list of funny
possibilities
oh i know my sandwich was in there
well at least now i'll be able to park
in san francisco
the two ant-man movies are pretty much
the funniest of all the mcu stand-alone
flicks the cast of both feature
performers with an act for comedy
including walton goggins michael pena
randall park and judy greer even so it's
a pleasant surprise for viewers to
suddenly encounter tim hydeker a comedy
innovator known for his bizarre boundary
pushing work on cult tv favorites like
tim and eric awesome show great job in
ant-man and the wasp he plays the leader
of a san francisco bay boat tour guide
some of heideker's best lines were
unfortunately left for the blooper reel
though i freak for whales i've loved
them ever since i was a kid i'm not
trained really in biology or knowing
anything about them i've memorized a
couple of facts but i couldn't go deep
black panther is a crowning achievement
in filmmaking and it also gave the world
one of the all-time great movie
catchphrases it even makes an appearance
in avengers infinity war
since black panther's release in early
2018 millions have flashed each other
the crossed arms salute by now everyone
knows how to say wakanda correctly but
during the film's production a few cast
members had trouble getting it down in
this clip neither martin freeman nor
danai guerrera are confident in their
ability that thing that was on your arm
is from wakanda what cam what
dr strange was a harder sell than your
typical superhero movie after all dr
steven strange's powers come from an
ability to connect with the worlds of
mysticism and magic to effectively
ground that in reality the filmmakers
required the services of an actor with
extensive classical training and an
impressive resume full of award-winning
dramatic roles that actor benedict
cumberbatch who earned widespread
acclaim for his work in sherlock and the
imitation game but who knew that
cumberbatch could be so silly underneath
all the pomp and circumstance he's just
as goofy on set as a wacky comic actor
judging from this blooper reel he's
especially down to get down breaking
into dance routines while filming his
scenes
it's apparently contagious because most
of his co-stars got in on the dance
craze too
one of television's longest running hits
is america's funniest home videos
debuting in 1990 this long-running
series has delighted the masses with
miles of poorly shot and grainy footage
of grown men getting hit in the private
parts the mcu movies for all their big
budget set pieces aren't immune to that
simple joy getting included on the
blooper reel did i get your testicles
[Music]
in the 80s and 90s jeff goldblum brought
a disarming charm and off-center
sensibility to his roles in otherwise
straightforward movies like jurassic
park and independence day in doing so he
made them much better than they would
have otherwise been without him it makes
sense then that when director taika
watiti took the thor movies in a cosmic
and comedic direction with thor ragnarok
he brought goldblum in for a role
goldblum plays the grand master the most
hedonistic of all the elders of the
universe the actor brings his trademark
looseness and an almost jazz like
approach to the movie which is
noticeable even when he's goofing off
between takes this
thor's wardrobe is about as eye-catching
as the lightning that often accompanies
the character in addition to chris
hemsworth's own indisputable good looks
thor usually rocks a tight metal shirt
rad pants and one undeniably great cape
but while the accessory might be stylish
it can be pretty temperamental on the
set of thor the dark world hemsworth
tries his best to act but he has trouble
due to an unpredictable co-star his cape
science fiction films and superhero
movies are full of mythology backstory
and their own sets of rules iron man 3
is a sci-fi film as well as a superhero
movie and it's got a lot of specific
words in jargon its actors need to
clearly and slowly deliver so the action
around them makes sense it's a delicate
balance to nail the terminology that's
been part of a comic or cinematic
universe for years so it satisfies both
hardcore and new fans alike that's why
marvel and its filmmakers hire top-notch
talent to deliver the written lines
actors like robert downey jr have the
training skill and talent necessary to
say all the technical talk in a
believable way still sometimes it's hard
to get those words out because even for
an actor of downey's caliber there's a
lot to remember in iron man 3 tony stark
has to recall his various super suits
there are a lot of them and in this
blooper downey jr needs the assistance
of the heartbreaker armor to help out
the armor whose name escapes him
heartbreaker will you help what's his
name
red
while the mcu movies enjoy a lot of cast
overlap for their various super heroic
characters black panther came out of
nowhere to introduce many fantastic
characters to the marvel cinematic
universe it also had the added benefit
of making huge stars out of the actors
and actresses who portrayed them
chadwick boseman had attained some fame
after playing jackie robinson and james
brown and 42 and get on up respectively
while lupita niango achieved her
breakthrough with 12 years a slave now
they're a-listers thanks to their roles
at the top of the cast of this superhero
action blockbuster deny guerrera
established a big screen career for
herself beyond her role as the katana
wielding michonne on the walking dead
but in this blooper she's quickly and
effectively upstaged by yet another
breakout mcu star
a goat
i know you have found something
[Music]
a sense of peace
[Music]
okay now you are going too far now
in spite of all the flying dragons game
of thrones is one of the most serious
shows in tv history and with all that
tension on screen the show's cast of
award-winning actors from all over the
world simply has to break the tension
from time to time that results in some
very charming if surprising bloopers
that will change the way you watch these
scenes in game of thrones
tyrion tongue twister peter dinklage has
won two emmys in a golden globe for his
portrayal of tyrion lannister the witty
less loved child of one of the most
powerful clans in westeros dinklage has
excellent diction honed over a long
career in front of cameras and yet
certain words on certain days can still
escape him in this blooper dinklage can
deliver a mouthful of george rr martin's
invented names but he can't get a handle
on a common english word no matter how
hard he tries
the wise masters of yonkai and the
penelope
[Music]
and the benevolent
and the benevolent
a watery grave
while off screen and awaiting us fate
for being arrested for the murder of
king joffrey tyrion has a serious
question for his brother jaime lannister
what's the punishment for regicide
drawing and quartering like any good
brother jaime gives him the brutal truth
and apparently that truth is enough to
make tyrion lose control of his bladder
drawing and quartering
[Music]
hound versus axe
in the sixth season of game of thrones
the hound played by rory mccann has been
taken under the wing of ian mcshane's
kind brother ray in one scene the hound
is hard at work chopping wood while
brother ray walks up to talk to him the
final cut has him effortlessly slicing
logs but behind the scenes it didn't go
so smoothly i don't believe in you
[Music]
strong and silent
esteemed british actor charles dance was
well cast as the mighty and imposing
patriarch tywin lannister as one of the
finest actors of his generation he gives
even the most dramatic scripts a little
something extra that's probably what
people unsaid thought dance was doing
when he took a long thoughtful pause
during a scene was he acting
nope
do i say something is it me what do i
say what
wedding date maybe for getting a line
and making it look like really good
acting runs in the lannister family when
tywin asks his daughter cersei lannister
when her wedding would be cersei pauses
for some of that lannister dramatic
effect
when would the wedding take place
in your mind
can't remember it seems that like her
on-screen dad she just happens to look
super serious when she's trying to think
of her lines
lannister lingo
on the other side of the coin actors are
just as liable to say too many words at
one time and deliver a bunch of
gibberish in this blooper it happened to
nikolai koster wildau when called out on
violating a promise jaime lannister has
the perfect excuse i was trying to get
back
burning back somebody almost got fired
for this mistake literally while filming
a scene as ober and martel actor pedro
pascal leaned against the wall a little
too close to where a torch was burning
unlike a lot of other things on game of
thrones that torch was not cgi it was
real fire and as pascal is reminded fire
is hot but now that i am
polite flub
in what's supposed to be a serious
conversation between jaime lannister and
brienne of tarth nikolai koster waldow
is delivering his lines normally right
up to the point he realizes he's saying
totally the wrong thing that flub
doesn't make co-star gwendolyn christie
break out into laughter what does is
cost her waldow's genuine heartfelt
apology for messing up the scene
iris dog hasn't been seen since her
father was killed
what do you think happened to her no
that's not what i'm saying i'm sorry
dance party
tyrion's tryout for the murder of
joffrey was a serious moment in season
four but during their entrance tyrion
and jamie just couldn't help lightening
the mood with the full song and dance
number their floor show continues all
the way into the courtroom and two
helmeted guards behind tyrion are even
framed just like backup dancers too bad
tyrion's case couldn't be decided by a
dance-off
it's always sad to watch your favorite
characters shuffle off this mortal coil
but it's even worse for the actors
involved who often have to film these
emotionally difficult scenes over and
over again it's no wonder then that
actors often try to lighten the mood by
goofing off right as their character is
kicking the bucket here's a look at some
unexpected bloopers during death scenes
inglorious bastards sally menke was an
academy award nominated film editor who
worked on nearly all of quentin
tarantino's films until she passed away
in 2010 while working with menke actors
and crew members on tarantino's films
would leave friendly messages for her
while shooting which she discovered
months later in the editing bay like
this bit from inglorious bastards actor
till schweiger sally
i am not dead i just pretended now i'm
gonna go after him and i'm gonna kick
his nazi
dracula dead and loving it mel brooks
virtually created the movie parody genre
making full length parodies of entire
film genres like blazing saddles
spaceballs and dracula dead and loving
it in one scene a pair of vampire
hunters played by brooks and stephen
weber needed to stake a vampire named
lucy webber barely held it together as
the scene plays out a little more
vigorously than he expected
oh
my
god
the avengers
all true fanboys and fan girls shed a
tear at the shocking loss of shield
agent phil coulson in marvel's
blockbuster the avengers but nobody took
it quite as hard as kobe smulders whose
agent maria hill simply expressed what
every one of us was feeling in that
dreadful moment
you are the greatest man i ever knew
and she didn't stop there you will be
avenged
you will be avenged
i will get the avengers and you will be
avenged cousin
jaws
as grizzled old quint and jaws robert
shaw got to have a spectacular gruesome
and memorable farewell the cast and crew
probably had no idea the scene would go
down on the annals of movie history
because to shaw it was downright
hilarious thanks to just a little too
much fake blood calling mel brooks
guardians of the galaxy vol 2. making
movies is tough work with shooting days
regularly lasting more than 14 hours as
crews prepare sets lighting props and
practical effects rigs that means a lot
of tired actors as michael rooker proved
in this scene from guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 since he was playing the
deceased yondu all he had to do was lie
there while his co-stars delivered a
heartfelt eulogy over his body but it
turned out to be just a little too
comfortable sometimes it's
right there by your side all along and
you don't even know it
even drax couldn't wake him
merlin
owen mackin portrayed sir gwen in the
long-running british series merlin right
up until the character was laid low by
treachery the once mighty guy expired in
the arms of his friend percival played
by tom hopper while sadly lamenting his
failure to stop the bad guys or at least
it should have been sad but hopper
apparently took it a little differently
[Laughter]
the interview
in seth rogen and james franco's
controversial 2014 comedy the interview
the duo played an american talk show
producer and host sent to north korea on
a mission to assassinate the nation's
leader kim jong-un along the way
brogan's character got into a fight to
the finish with a north korean agent but
as this blooper shows the two actors
weren't exactly treating it like a
moment where life hangs in the balance
game of thrones when jon snow was
assassinated on game of thrones by his
own men at the end of season five it was
one of the most shocking moments ever on
the hbo fantasy series so would the red
witch be able to bring him back to life
during season six
some of the most memorable scenes in
hollywood history were actually
unscripted adding a flicker of
authenticity to an otherwise artificial
yet finely crafted final product these
would-be bloopers were too good to leave
on the cutting room floor so the
directors kept them in the final edit
instead where they live on as rare
glimpses of actors dropping their masks
if only for a moment django unchained
one of jango's chief aims in this 2012
western is to free his wife from the
clutches of terrifyingly crazed slave
owner calvin candy the meeting between
jamie foxx's django and leonardo
dicaprio's calvin is extremely tense and
for dramatic effect dicaprio slams his
hand on a table and right onto a glass
you lay your palm flat on that table top
if you lift those palms off that turtle
shell tabletop mr pooch is going to let
loose both fails that start off dicaprio
didn't stop at all during the take even
though he just seriously lacerated his
hand nonchalantly picking out the pieces
of glass and even lighting a cigarette
blade runner
daryl hannah took home a souvenir from
the set of blade runner in the form of a
scar on her arm and the take in which
she injured it making its way into the
movie while playing a replicant named
priss hannah ran from william
sanderson's genetic designer jf
sebastian and slipped onto the wet
pavement
[Music]
hey breaking the window wasn't planned
but hannah finished filming the scene
preserving what ended up being a fairly
serious injury for posterity the hateful
eight for her role as the manipulative
outlaw daisy and quentin tarantino's the
hateful eight jennifer jason lee had to
know how to play a little guitar she
learned on a vintage 19th century martin
on loan to the production from the
martin guitar museum in one scene lee's
co-star kurt russell was supposed to
yank the instrument out of her hands and
smash it to smithereens but the cameras
were supposed to cut first so it could
be swapped out for an ordinary guitar
music time's over
but the cut didn't come and russell
unknowingly destroyed the antique martin
valued at forty thousand dollars so
lee's reaction is the real thing
true lies james cameron's 1994 spy
comedy contains some of the biggest and
most expensive sequences in movie
history but the one scene from true lies
everybody remembers two decades later is
jaime lee curtis's striptease her
character helen takes off her clothes
for a man she believes to be an arms
dealer but is actually her husband harry
played by arnold schwarzenegger curtis's
sexy moment is interrupted briefly when
she loses her balance
[Music]
it's a perfect pratfall with impeccable
comic timing but it wasn't in cameron's
script curtis didn't want to do the
scene the way it was scripted which
called for her to get completely naked
and filmed in silhouette cameron agreed
to her changes and they worked out the
choreography without schwarzenegger's
knowledge so that's a genuine reaction
from schwarzenegger who thought the fall
would ultimately just end up as a
blooper
midnight cowboy the 1969 low budget
classic midnight cowboy features one of
the most famous unscripted lines in
movie history as dustin hoffman's ratzo
rizzo and jon voigt's joe buck are
walking across a very busy and very real
manhattan street having a conversation a
cab nearly hits
hoffman i'm walking
hoffman's response was so perfectly in
character that director john slashinger
kept it in the film which went on to win
best picture at the academy awards annie
hall it's a scene originally meant to
serve as just a transition allowing
woody allen's proud new yorker character
alvey and his girlfriend annie to
mention they're taking a trip to los
angeles but has become a classic bit of
physical comedy thanks to an unplanned
moment a stash of cocaine said to be
worth two thousand dollars an ounce is
passed around at a party eventually
arriving at alvey
what is the kick of it
allen says it was a complete unplanned
accident but test screen audiences
laughed uproariously at it so alan also
the director of the movie kept it in
marvel's two guardians of the galaxy
installments are action-packed exciting
and even meaningful best of all they're
really funny usually that humor is
intentional but sometimes it's a
complete accident which is great because
these bloopers make us love guardians of
the galaxy even more
rooker books it you think walking and
chewing gum at the same time is hard try
walking and talking sure it sounds like
something you do every day but as actors
michael rooker and tom proctor prove
here it's not always as easy as it seems
he wants cargo and you go he's going
soft on it
you walked us right off the set yes i
can come on i'm gonna do it again a
blooper from a galaxy far far away kurt
russell is a living legend but even
legends sometimes screw up their lines
like in this blooper where russell
accidentally gives a shout out to the
franchise that inspired much of the
space action in guardians of the galaxy
wow even where i reside out past the
edge of what's known we've heard tell
about the man they call star wars
you could be in trouble rock it to the
gag reel
groot and rocket raccoon are the result
of the combined magic of cgi the voice
work of stars vin diesel and bradley
cooper and motion capture and thank
goodness the movies used real-life human
stand-ins for the tree man and his trash
panda buddy because how else would a
blooper featuring these two characters
even be possible i
nonsense
here's a blooper stuffed tape that made
its way into the final cut of guardians
of the galaxy while dealing with a rare
goods dealer known as the broker yondu
frustrates and upsets the guy by
mumbling a bunch of gibberish it's a
little more than co-star sean gunn could
handle and director james gunn kept the
result in the film
more nonsense
it's apparently no sweat for michael
rooker to make up his own real sounding
nonsense words in a pinch but give the
guy some comic book slash science
fiction movie dialogue heavy on the
technical side and he just can't get the
words out without stumbling whoops
franklin we need an extraction
quadrant
[Music]
lee pace loses his place
prior to joining the marvel cinematic
universe lee pace worked primarily as an
actor in more straightforward dramas
those roles didn't necessarily prepare
him for the bonkers role of ronin the
accuser as this blooper of pace
struggling to nail the role shows wait
one more time what was that so
duh
then turn
today
power becomes the only law
wait that's all right is it chris pratt
doinks around
finally the encounter between the
guardians of the galaxy and the alien
ruler aisha drives much of the conflict
in the second film but it could have all
gone very differently if star-lord had
gotten his way he didn't but at least
the effort left us with this amazing gym
i personally control half the dna by
doing something i call doinking
it's safe to say that star wars is
likely the most popular film series of
all time not only have the official
chapters and growing number of offshoots
brought in billions of dollars they've
captivated hundreds of millions the
world over with classic stories of good
triumphing over evil but it takes a lot
of money time and effort to put a star
wars movie together which means once in
a while someone's going to blow a take
for example super blooper sci-fi films
naturally include dialogue with a lot of
technical words alien planets and races
unusual character names and assorted of
the jargon actors have to work hard to
memorize all that stuff or at least be
able to read it off of cue cards
properly but it's a fairly simple word
that ended up throwing off mark hamill
while filming a scene inside an x-wing
now let's get some distance before that
thing goes
now let's get some distance before that
thing goes supernova
how do you pronounce supernova what's
inflection supernova or supernova
man vs sword round one it would seem
that the proper handling of a lightsaber
is not really among actor liam neeson's
well particular set of skills
anyway while portraying qui-gon jin in
the phantom menace nissan tried to
smoothly unsheath star wars trademark
weapon but as this take proves he wasn't
quite a real life jedi master
let's see that again
smooth
tongue tied tarkin
bloopers can add a fascinating dimension
to extremely familiar movie scenes take
for example this well-known moment from
a new hope in which princess leia begs
and pleads with the stone-hearted
governor turkin not to blow up her
adopted home planet actor peter cushing
reels around to chastise her but gets
tongue-tied no run is peaceful we have
no weapons you will prefer another
target a military target then name the
the
name it now before i go home man versus
sword round two at some point in the
last 40 years thousands of kids have
staged an epic imaginary lightsaber
battle in their bedroom in this blooper
hayden christensen looks just like a
star wars loving little boy up to the
moment he loses his balance and feels a
force of gravity
okay
stuck stormtroopers blindly serving the
evil darth vader stormtroopers are
intimidating cutthroat and unemotional
agents of death and destruction what
could possibly stop their march of doom
a hole too small to fit through
apparently as seen in this blooper from
a new hope
droid down
from the first star wars film until his
death in 2016 actor kenny baker operated
r2d2 from the inside it's easy to forget
that r2 is actually a relatively clunky
costume and not actually an advanced
droid that means it can tip over all the
controls can suddenly go out as they did
in these bloopers from the phantom
menace
let it go
saying the right words moving your body
around the right way and interacting
with other actors all at the same time
and in the correct order can be a lot to
remember and if an actor screws up just
one of those little things it ruins a
take in this scene from attack of the
clones hayden christensen knew he was
supposed to let go of natalie portman's
arm he just did it way too early where
are you going to find everyone no you're
not let go of me
obi-wan kenobi after being offered the
role of obi-wan kenobi but before taking
the part alec guinness called it fairy
tale rubbish he later wrote in a letter
during filming that he didn't enjoy
making the movie in part due to what he
called rubbish dialogue that resentment
from the legendary english actor is on
display in this blooper from the set of
a new hope after he's upstaged by one of
chewbacca's hairy arms
here's where the fun begins
well
remember lines he cannot even the most
vocal the phantom menace detractor of
which there are many has to admit that a
highlight from the first long-awaited
star wars prequel was the return of yoda
frank oz returned to provide the jedi
master's grammatically wonky voice and
even though oz wasn't physically on
camera at all he still seemed to get
nervous on set
always true there are
no more
nor less
um now i'll forgot man
can i cut george
whether she's laying waste to king's
landing or falling in love amelia clark
has played a lot of intense scenes in
movies and on tv on set though she seems
like a genuinely endearing person with a
great sense of humor and we've got the
bloopers to prove it game of thrones
presented a unique series of challenges
for all of its actors the show wasn't
exactly full house but with its location
shooting in far-flung locales all over
the world dense literary dialogue and
special effects heavy sequences amelia
clark in particular had to continually
juggle all of these elements as she
portrayed daenerys targaryen a character
who traveled extensively spoke multiple
languages and soared on the backs of
fire breathing beasts however everyone
is human even the mother of dragons and
mistakes will be made for one scene
clark had to deliver a whole lot of
dialogue in the tricky fictional
language of dothraki while sitting on an
inanimate device that would eventually
become a cgi dragon that's plenty for
any actor to handle and clark
understandably had a few rough spots
delivering her dothraki lines
i knock it back
[Music]
of course she didn't lose her cool and
stayed in great spirits in fact when
clark loosened up and jokingly ad-libbed
some dialogue her dothraki actually
sounded pretty natural
my
emilia clarke was born and raised in
england a country that's relatively
small but rich with a surprisingly high
volume of accents among many others
there's a distinctive liverpool accent
that fans the beatles might recognize
and the crisp classy accent favored by
actors and actresses in highbrow british
television shows that's the kind clarke
used for her role as daenerys and it
isn't all that different from her
natural southern england accent but as a
trained and experienced actress she can
recognize and replicate the differences
between her country's many dialects one
particular scene features actor michiel
houseman who portrayed daenerys's loyal
advisor and lover dario naharis
approaching her with a variety of wild
flowers in the outtake of the scene
clark breaks the tension and surprises
everyone with a perfect east london
cockney accent i'm a kalisi not a queen
obviously game of thrones doesn't take
place in any real historical time period
it's a sweeping fantasy set in a world
of dragons and supernatural threats
still most of the characters seem to
have british accents for some reason in
a clip from the 8th season's blooper
reel daenerys sits down for a chat with
sansa stark a rare moment of quiet and
civility before another round of
violence at this point in the show's
timeline daenerys has taken jon snow as
a lover and everyone thinks that he is a
bastard member of the stark family and
sansa's brother spoiler alert it turns
out that jon is a targaryen just like
his aunt daenerys but that little bit of
info is neither here nor there as clark
uses the attractiveness of kit
harington's jon snow as jumping off
point to improv in a modern slang laced
dialect
which is fancier for the loads
in all of her playful behind the scenes
footage as well as in her many
promotional interviews clark seems like
an endlessly charming and grounded
person she definitely doesn't embody
that hollywood stereotype of the
pretentious self-absorbed nightmare diva
who can never be pleased but if clark
did act like that her behavior might not
be completely unexpected after all she
starred on one of the biggest tv shows
in history for eight seasons and she
became an international celebrity in the
process in a hilarious montage that
clark shot for glamour magazine she
gives viewers a taste of what it might
have been like if she let all the fame
and acclaim go to her head where's my
wigs
where's my orange mocha frappuccino
where are my kale chips after more
tongue-in-cheek inquiries about toilet
paper spanx uber and her boyfriend she
saves the most important question for
last
where's my privacy do you know what i
mean bye
by 2016 game of thrones had been airing
for five successful seasons allowing
amelia clark to spread her wings and
star in major films in me before you
actor sam claflin plays a man named will
who is despondent after he's been
paralyzed in a terrible accident clark
plays lou a paid companion hired to help
will and raise his spirits it should
come as no surprise that after an
awkward start the two fell madly in love
with each other lou is about as far away
from daenerys as possible between takes
though the set of me before you had a
lot in common with the set of game of
thrones in that clark's kind-hearted wit
in the face of goof-ups was on full
display in one outtake clark is supposed
to be driving a car but as we all know
cars don't work properly if the
handbrake is engaged that's what seems
to be happening with this particular
vehicle and it immediately throws clark
off her game until a crew member comes
to the rescue if you put my handbrake
right
it's a really good start
emilia clarke might always be most
associated with a breakthrough role of
daenerys stormborn of the house
targaryen the first of her name queen of
mirin khaleesi of the great grass sea
mother of dragons and so forth so many
titles carry with them so much class and
dignity but at her core daenerys is just
another person and so is clark
possessing a regular human body that may
make embarrassing sounds from time to
time it's unclear if an audible eruption
on the set of me before you actually
came from clark or if it was the result
of a squeaky couch cushion or some piece
of malfunctioning movie making equipment
but the telltale sound of a massive gas
leak definitely emanated from clark's
general direction
somehow her co-star sam claflin doesn't
immediately laugh and keeps it together
for a few seconds until he finally
cracks up alongside clark
[Music]
so in the end it seems that daenerys
never fulfilled her ambition of breaking
the wheel but clark clearly made her
mark by breaking wind it stinks like
death
don't think i can't smell it
with the show as hilarious as the office
it's definitely worth taking the time to
watch all the blooper reels
okay wait how do you know it's a
warehouse worker that's dunk up the
bathroom they stink up the bathroom with
their smelly poo so
jenna they're gonna turn on us come on
if you don't have a lot of time on your
hands never fear we've rounded up some
of the very best blooper reels from the
office right here
in the season 2 episode office olympics
michael takes dwight to the condo he's
hoping to purchase dwight wastes no time
making his boss highly uncomfortable
pointing out a string of potential
problems wow you'll be paying this off
in your mid-70s
forget about retiring when you're 65.
but in this blooper from the episode
it's dwight or rather actor rayne wilson
who seems really rather uncomfortable
and the reason why soon becomes clear i
love you i love you michael i love you
too what are you even talking about i
was just talking about i farted
are you kidding me great to know that
actors go through the same struggles as
the rest of us
sometimes actors can really miss the
mark take phillip smith for example come
on phyllis come on
oh jesus are you all right
fellas are you all right are you okay
i'm okay she's not the only office actor
who occasionally fails at sticking the
landing it seems brian baumgartner has
yet to master the subtle art of sitting
down
don't don't you even
keep that in there
meanwhile in the season 5 episode
michael scott paper company steve carell
encounters some serious car trouble
i think i'm gonna need some new pants
hey no one ever said getting out of cars
was easy
we all have our things well actor john
krasinski evidently likes to pretend to
get his finger caught in clapperboards
who wouldn't want to try their hand at
that clearly brian baumgartner was eager
to get in on all the fun
that's my joke
it's my joke
and here comes jenna fisher to show him
how it's really done
teamwork he didn't get me
everyone put your hands together for
these clap aboard kooks
in the season 7 episode viewing party
the whole staff gathers at gabe's
apartment to watch glee and make
homemade pizzas so these are your
cheeses your hams your sausages your
herbs and your vegetables here's what's
been done let's start creating early on
in the episode michael is seen throwing
pizza dough in the air and then this
happens try to destroy the old ways gabe
i will not let you
but in one unused take the scene goes a
little bit differently bon appetit try
to destroy the old ways gabe i will not
let you do it
[Laughter]
for an actor staying in character takes
a lot of hard work and it can be tough
to remember all those lines in a scene
from the season 4 episode dinner party
dwight unexpectedly arrives at michael's
condo with two wine glasses and a creepy
date
coming
hello
what are you doing here we came here to
eat dinner and to party obviously the
scene wasn't shot in one take as this
ridiculous blooper proves
what are you doing here hi how are you
hi i'm not in character yet
hey
at least he's being honest throughout
season six pam does everything in her
power to hold off labor as she wrestles
with the fear of giving birth in a scene
from the episode to the delivery part
one michael gathers the staff to
brainstorm how to slow down pam's
pregnancy as erin reads off a list of
ways to stimulate labor the group
suggests ways of doing the exact
opposite okay number three eat spicy
foods okay the opposite of that stick
spicy food up her butt nope nope for
obvious reasons it took a bit of work
before to nail down this particular
scene take one what is the opposite of
that make spicy foods come out of her
okay no no
take two
spicy foods come out of no okay nope
nope we're not doing that pam
take three and the opposite of that oh
make spicy food
turns out practice does make perfect
let's watch the final cut one more time
to bask in the glory okay uh number
three eat spicy foods okay the opposite
of that stick spicy food upper butt nope
nope
it was only a matter of time before
chris pratt became an a-list movie star
he's now at the center of multiple
franchises he's star-lord and guardians
of the galaxy owen in jurassic world and
emmett in the lego movie but pratt
slowly built up his career with regular
roles on tv and supporting roles in big
screen productions before earning his
spot on the top throughout it all pratt
has proven to be a charming entertaining
and most of all hilarious guy here are
some times that the camera captured him
on movie and tv sets goofing off
screwing up and ad-libbing
the oc
one of pratt's earliest roles was
playing che on fox's team soap the oc
and while the part mostly required him
to act like a burnout he did seem to
have a lot of fun with it until he had
to eat on camera that is in one scene he
was supposed to be giving sage advice to
seth cohen while eating a bowl of figs
and it probably would have gone off
without a hitch if pratt hadn't grabbed
a spoiled piece of fruit
what's your number
wearing a fat suit might hinder some
actors ability to bust a move but that
wasn't the case for chris pratt and
what's your number pratt had to bulk up
a bit but he still managed to bust out
some impressively accurate michael
jackson dance moves that were totally
uninhibited by the extra poundage he
should put that on his resume
parks and recreation pratt didn't come
out of nowhere to become the biggest
action hero working today before he
started saving the world he was best
known for his supporting role in nbc
comedy parks and recreation but the
inklings of a hero were still present in
his role as the dumb but eager man child
andy dwyer in this outtake pratt rapidly
hurdled over a counter and then ditched
a briefcase his character didn't need to
steal by throwing it back from where he
got it amazingly the case nailed the
light switch and left the actors in the
dark
hilarious
that's not something that props can fix
i'm sorry i'm out
delivery man
even though chris pratt was on the cusp
of mega success when he starred in this
2013 comedy he was still pretty hungry
at least that's all we can assume from
watching this outtake of him chasing a
lot of cash from blowing away in the
wind
why not it's not too real
is that too real
jurassic world
pratt's character owen can do a lot of
things he can ride a motorcycle he can
tame velociraptors and he can even make
the t-rex look like a good guy but
acting out one of owen's talents in
particular gave chris pratt some trouble
on the set while his character was
capable of doing crazy things pratt had
a lot of trouble whistling and the
behind the scenes footage of his
repeated failed efforts made for some
great b-roll
i'll get it
guardians of the galaxy
flying a spaceship is fun and it would
seem that even pretending to fly a
spaceship is also a thrill because on
the set of guardians of the galaxy pratt
got a little carried away behind the
controls of the mighty milano the
filmmakers probably only really needed a
second or two of star-lord looking
excited but pratt got downright maniacal
with his unbridled glee
[Applause]
guardians of the galaxy vol 2. the
guardians returned for some more outer
space adventures in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 but they weren't alone a
few new characters came along including
an ageless celestial named ego who was
star-lord's father played by kurt
russell because the movie was set on
several distant planets gravity wasn't
always a given so to replicate that the
actors had to endure a lot of wire work
and in this outtake from the movie pratt
and russell had a hard time getting the
hang of things
the film also presented another all-star
blooper when we were introduced to the
high priestess of the sovereigns she
tried to chat up the star-lord about
breeding techniques and she got this as
an explanation of how earthlings do it
i personally control half the dna by
doing something i call doinking
passengers
for a large portion of his other space
movie passengers chris pratt wandered
around a gigantic ship almost entirely
by himself his only human interaction
was with an android bartender named
arthur played by michael sheen arthur
provided drinks and a little bit of
companionship and since there wasn't
much else to do pratt's character was a
patron of the pub quite often in this
outtake pratt got a chance to do some
drunk acting and he comically
overreacted to arthur's boozy blue
concoction
there's coconut in it
it's amazing none of these moments made
it into the movies really
accidents will happen but once in a
while their blessings in disguise take
tv show bloopers sometimes they make the
show funnier more convincing or just
more all-around interesting these
bloopers from popular tv shows were just
so perfect for the plot and characters
they had to stay in the final cut
seinfeld the best seinfeld episodes
featured the fabulous foursome
struggling with some kind of existential
nightmare perhaps the best example is
the 1991 episode the parking garage in
which the gang spends the entire story
wandering around a parking complex
unable to find their car until the very
end as scripted the episode was supposed
to finish with some small talk and the
group driving off their struggle finally
over but when actor michael richards put
the key in the ignition the car wouldn't
start an unplanned ending that cracked
up the cast and crew
[Music]
it's a more fitting and funnier way to
wrap up the story and it proved just too
good to cut
supernatural
a commonly uttered profane phrase
doubled as a catchphrase for paranormal
investigator dean winchester on
supernatural actor jason ackles uttered
the line as an offscript addition while
making the 2007 episode bad day at
blackrock
son of a [ __ ]
his boisterous hilariously frustrated
over-the-top delivery did a number on
co-star jared padalecki and the inspired
improvisation made it into the final
episode
friends
ross geller was always a man with quirky
pursuits like playing experimental
keyboard music and owning a monkey for
example in the seventh season friends
episode the one with joey's new brain
ross desperately wants to play the
bagpipes at chandler and monica's
upcoming wedding even though they aren't
interested and despite his complete
inability to actually play the
instrument during a sneak peek actress
jennifer aniston clearly can't handle it
and does everything in her power to not
break a real life reaction too good to
leave on the cutting room floor
how i met your mother
wayne brady's first big claim to fame
was as a gifted improvisational comic on
abc's whose line is it anyway in brady's
first episode as barney's brother on the
sitcom how i met your mother actor neil
patrick harris made it his mission to
improvise a line that would make brady
crack the one that worked a reference to
a song by britney spears backup dancer
turned husband kevin federline what what
what cool help us out
brady had to quickly duck away to keep
from cracking up on camera an awkward
bit of blocking but the end result was
too funny to cut
the brady bunch
in his 1992 memoir growing up brady
barry williams revealed he taped the
scene for the ultra innocent family
sitcom while completely stoned to be
fair he was a young dude in california
in the early 70s and he thought he had
the day off but then he got a call from
the producers who needed him on the set
that day after all
oops
far out
somehow nobody associated with the brady
bunch thought it was weird that williams
tripped over his bike pump awkwardly
waved slurred his words or looked the
wrong way when his on-screen little
sister arrived on scene all with a dopey
grin on his face or maybe a secret hero
knew what was up and decided to leave it
in as a gift to future generations
mystery science theater 3000 this cult
classic follows the interstellar
travails of a poor sap imprisoned on a
spaceship with a crew of robots mocking
the low budget movies they're forced to
watch many of the films are riddled with
mistakes so it's ironic that mst 3k had
its own spectacular blooper make it into
the finished product inspired by a
weapon in a terrible movie called danger
death ray tom servo made his own death
ray and fired it a crow that was all
supposed to happen oh i gotta admit it
it is pretty funny
the crow puppet however wasn't supposed
to catch fire it was just the sort of
anarchic silliness that made mystery
science theater 3000 so special so if
the take was used
one of the best things about the home
releases of marvel movies is that they
almost always come with a gag reel
here's some examples of marvel movie
bloopers we think might even be better
than the original scenes
in 2004 spider-man 2 peter parker isn't
finding young adulthood easy he may have
superpowers and genius level intellect
but the challenge of juggling college
multiple jobs a social life and fighting
crime as spider-man is proving too much
for him
in one of the many scenes meant to show
how parker is struggling he drops his
textbooks and as he kneels down to
retrieve them multiple passing students
whack him in the head with their bags
the movie's gag reel shows us one take
when things went even worse for parker
although thankfully maguire has a good
sense of humor about it shortly after
parker is hit from behind by one
student's bag he's hit by another from
the front a prompt shows us the second
student is none other than the director
of the first spider-man film trilogy sam
raimi
although the extended battering of peter
would have definitely made the finish
scene funnier perhaps raymie decided
that choking his lead actor with a
backpack was going a little too far
on the avengers gag reel mark ruffalo
proves himself to either have a wealth
of underutilized slapstick comedy
potential or to simply be the clumsiest
actor on just about any superhero movie
set you could find in the middle of
filming one of his lab scenes with
robert downey jr ruffalo calls for the
crew to wait while he resets a prop
which proves easier said than done
careful electron set
sorry
i got it
it's okay it's coming
while this clumsiness actually would
have worked well for bruce banner's
character it may have been a little too
silly for the high stakes world of the
avengers
dude you're on your own
in what the avengers blu-ray calls
marvel's first ever gag reel it's clear
that director joss whedon's trademark
sense of humor infected the entire cast
but whedon's not the only one who gets
to make you laugh as shield agent maria
hill kobe smulders doesn't get to flex
her comedy muscles in the mcu as often
as she did on how i met your mother
however she makes up for it with what's
arguably the funniest moment in the
avengers bloopers pretending to react to
the news of phil coulson's death
smulders has what we'll call a dramatic
reaction
oh god
you are the greatest man i ever knew
we can't in good conscience pretend
maria hill's over-the-top meltdown would
have fit into the actual movie but
there's no denying it would have been
hilarious
the first time captain america iron man
and thor meet in the avengers things
don't go that well the thunder god
kidnaps loki from the quinjet prompting
iron man to fly after him intending to
follow him cap grabs a parachute and
jumps out of the plane but in the gag
reel things went a little differently on
the reel chris evans still grabs the
parachute but has absolutely no idea how
to get the thing on he struggles with it
for so long that it gets to the point
where you start to genuinely feel bad
for the guy i guess it would only go up
as smoothly as i was hoping
while it would have taken away from the
intensity of the scene showing this in
the finished film might actually have
made sense for the character after all
the last time steve rogers used a
parachute was decades earlier and the
design could have significantly changed
since world war ii seeing steve struggle
with his modern parachute could have
been yet another amusing reminder that
although you can take the captain out of
the 1940s you can't take the 1940s out
of the captain
in one of the funnier moments of 2014's
guardians of the galaxy michael rooker's
yondu chooses a unique intimidation
tactic while the broker tries to explain
why he can't give yondu the information
he wants yondu keeps interrupting him
with gibberish while this is already
humorous in the movie in the gag reel it
ventures into the realm of the absurd as
rooker just keeps going
behind him you can even see co-star sean
gunn trying hard not to laugh in a few
takes sure we think the finished scene
is funny enough but adding in rooker's
extended gibberish monologue would have
taken it to the next level
sylvester stallone and kurt russell have
a few things in common they both hit
their fame sweet spots in the 1980s they
both appear in 2017's guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 and both get frustrated on
the sequel's gag reel trying to spit out
guardian's specific names the gag reel
shows that while playing the ravager
leaders to car stallone had a lot of
trouble nailing down the word ravager
ravager
what am i saying ravinger no
brav verger yes oh forget it i'll see
you in looping
meanwhile kurt russell has trouble
saying his son's code name
as he camps with the guardians russell
says
well even where i reside out past the
edge of what's known we've heard tell
about the man they call star wars
of course we all know the name he really
means to say is
star-lord
who star-lord man legendary outlaw
russell immediately realizes his mistake
and eventually manages to get his son's
name right however leaving in the
actor's mistakes could have added a bit
to the respective scenes showing stakar
pronouncing ravagers differently than
yandu could have highlighted the
division between the two of them and the
fact that ego keeps getting his kid's
name mixed up with that of a popular
earth movie franchise could underscore
what a horrible father he is well of
course i have issues
that's my freaking father
the scene set in the dystopian future of
2014's x-men days of future past have a
pretty bleak tone so it almost feels
wrong that the movie even has a gag reel
but it's good that it does since the
outtakes are pretty hilarious among
other funny bits the gag reel includes a
ridiculous alternate version of a
deleted scene before time traveling to
the past to prevent the dystopian future
in which the sentinels have hunted
mutants to near extinction wolverine
turns to storm
after confirming that he'll be the only
one to remember this version of the
future he gives his teammate a long kiss
although the scene is likely supposed to
end there halle berry follows it up with
an unexpected reaction in the gag reel
although barry's response to the kiss
would have broken the bleak mood the
kiss itself may have been a nice
addition to the finished film on the
other hand sharing a kiss with storm
earlier in the film might have made
seeing her right before wolverine's
emotional reunion with the previously
deceased jean grey at the end of the
film slightly more awkward
as far as mcu movies go 2016's captain
america civil war is pretty intense the
final throwdown between the warring
heroes gets ugly but thankfully one of
the architects of marvel comics shows up
toward the end to not only deliver an
important package to tony stark but to
make sure we get in a few laughs in one
of his many beloved marvel cameos the
late stan lee shows up to the avengers
headquarters as a fedex driver
delivering the package that contains a
letter from steve rogers along with an
emergency contact phone in the finished
product lee accidentally misreads the
name of the recipient much to roadie's
delight
are you tony's stank
yes this is this is tony stank
you're in the right place thank you for
that
however the film's gag reel shows a take
where lee says something else and we're
not sure if he did it on purpose or if
it was a legitimate goof are you robert
stank
while the original scene was hilarious
fusing the mispronunciation of the
character's last name with the actor's
real-life first name could have been a
fun fourth wall breaking moment it even
would have made an odd sort of sense
considering that marvel has officially
canonized the popular fan theory that
lee is playing a watcher in all of his
cameos
the blooper reel on the home release for
2016's deadpool makes it clear that
several of the actors frequently veered
off script deadpool's gag reel includes
a wealth of completely improvised lines
particularly from ryan reynolds and his
co-star tj miller for example when
miller's weasel first sees wade wilson's
scarred face the comedian unleashes a
torrent of improvised takedowns
expressing his disgust at his friend's
new appearance you look like somebody
turned your face inside out and then
just left it like that but then you got
in a house fire god you look like a
house fire was in another house fire
meanwhile reynold's own improv includes
a long list of jabs toward gina carano's
angel dust leave me all alone here with
busta rhymes you're gonna leave me all
alone here with henry winkler gonna
leave me all alone here with hey you
guys
hilariously the reel shows that the line
that made it into the theatrical release
ticked carano off so much she gave
reynolds an actual punch to the face as
a reward sorry gina
while it's true that putting all of
miller's and reynolds improvised
outtakes into the finished film probably
wouldn't have worked from a pacing
perspective we wouldn't have minded
giving each of them an opportunity to
riff just a little bit longer in each of
these scenes
one of the most delightful parts of
2018's deadpool 2 is wade wilson's
corrective time romp during the
mid-credits scenes deadpool uses cable's
repaired time travel device to save his
girlfriend and his x-force teammate
peter prevent the making of the 2011
film green lantern and cut short the
action of 2009's x-men origins wolverine
but while negasonic teenage warhead has
a surprisingly easy time fixing the
device deadpool has a tough time
grabbing a hold of it on the gag reel we
learned that it took ryan reynolds at
least four takes to catch the device
without dropping it considering how
ridiculous the deadpool films tend to be
we can't help but wonder if the main
character repeatedly fumbling the time
travel device might have actually played
well in the film maybe wade could have
even capped the moment with his
signature slogan
maximum effort
there's one little wonderful nugget
about the making of the star wars
prequels that fans of the franchise love
even if they aren't particularly fond of
the films themselves according to ewan
mcgregor the obi-wan kenobi actor would
regularly make the lightsaber sound
effects with his mouth during fight
scenes to begin with it was quite
difficult not to make the sound yeah
and also when it goes away because it
makes that nice
noise when it goes down
well according to the gag reel for
2017's thor ragnarok mcgregor isn't
alone in accidentally trying to do the
sound team's job for them kate blanchett
plays the death goddess hella in
ragnarok and the gag reel includes a few
takes of different scenes in which
blanchett makes childlike sound effects
to accompany the unleashing of her
character's powers
do i shouldn't make the noises in my
mouth today
the gag reel also reveals that
blanchett's fight scenes with co-star
chris hemsworth offered other challenges
the oscar-winning actress had a tough
time dragging her co-star across the
floor as well as finding it tough to not
hit hemsworth for real sorry guys
i've been training for months but i
don't think i can lift that
sure maybe hella wouldn't have been
quite as intimidating if she was making
her own sound effects and fumbling her
fights with her super-powered siblings
but in a film filled with plenty of
other visual and audible gags including
blanchet's goofs may not have felt
entirely out of place improvisation is a
great tool for actors and directors it
improves morale on the set because it
makes the performers feel like they're a
larger part of the creative process as
they try to find lines that are better
or funnier than the screenplay but
sometimes a noble attempt to improv
cracks up the cast and leads to an
unusable outtake for example
anchorman
a laughter free take of this scene made
it into the credits of this classic
retro comedy including a line while
feral apparently made up on the spot but
that doesn't mean the whole take was
laughter free it comes early in the
movie when ron burgundy is conducting
vocal warm-ups and the minutes leading
up to live news broadcast one is so
ridiculous that even a pro-like feral
can't handle it the skeleton ran out of
shampoo in the shower
the human torch could not get a bank
loan
the
the human torch was denied a bank loan
anchorman two while filming the c
quarter 2004's anchorman writer director
adam mckay threw out line suggestions on
the spot for young actor judah nelson
one involving warm equine urine the kid
gives it his all but he can't quite get
through it you know i don't want to
drink hot frothy horse
i don't want to drink
from fourth
this is forte
jed apatow is a director that likes to
feed improvised lines to his actors
while billy joe armstrong of green day
has no problem playing punk rock in
front of thousands of rowdy fans
repeating one of apato's off-the-cut
jokes while filming this as 40 made him
lose his composure maybe it hit a little
too close to home yeah i'm really trying
to get back in touch with my anger
it's hard to stay angry when you're this
rich
it's hard to stay angry when you're
the 40 year old virgin
some actors and directors work together
so often that they develop a rapport
that results in movie magic real life
couple leslie mann and jodapato are
definitely on that list in this clip
from the filming of the 40 year old
virgin it's clear that apatow treats man
like any other actor providing on the
spotlight suggestions to improve the
scene man is game at first but then
breaks character when apatow crosses a
line do you wanna [ __ ] in the car so do
you wanna [ __ ] in the car no you do you
like ecstasy let's do some e in my house
what ecstasy honey we have kids
train wreck
lebron james is obviously a great
basketball player but who would have
thought to be such a charming and funny
actor he holds his own as a thrifty
sensitive version of himself and
trainwreck opposite formidable comic
talents like amy schumer and bill hader
james rolls of all the improvised lines
fed to him cracking up his co-stars i
had tortilla soup i can't get a
hamburger look how big i am i think a
tortilla soup is gonna last me the rest
of the day
the hangover
when your movie stars are veteran of the
office and the daily show and a
one-of-a-kind stand-up comedian it's
best to just let them do their thing in
this scene from the first entry in the
hangover trilogy ed helms and zach
galifianakis engage in a rapidly
escalating war of words reaching absurd
specific and ridiculous heights you look
like
someone puked hair on your chest
you look like someone puked hair on your
face
you guys did you see his body you look
like you just swallowed two frozen
turkeys happy thanksgiving
what
why do people keep making movies about a
guy who shoots webs out of his wrists
because they're fun and that's not just
true for the audience the people making
them seem to be having a blast too here
are some times when things got a little
silly on set
in spider-man homecoming tom holland's
peter parker has a full and busy life in
addition to super heroics he's got to
juggle homework with a spot on his
school's academic team not to mention
working as an intern at stark industries
in one scene he tries to talk his way
out of an upcoming academic decathlon
and his advisor won't take no for an
answer peter sputters off a list of his
responsibilities and it turns out that
responsibilities are something of a
trigger word it's the crux of a
spider-man mantra after all when he
flubs the line he can't help but break
character give a right turn to the
camera and recite the phrase predecessor
toby maguire made mainstream stark and
my internship you know i i got a lot of
um responsibility with it
with great power comes great
responsibility
when spider-man 2 opens peter parker has
already endured a lot of spider-man he's
in college at this point but still the
same clumsy guy in public picking up
none of the gracefulness of his
superhero side in one scene peter drops
all of his books and school supplies
while walking on campus that was
supposed to happen what came as a
surprise to toby maguire was what
happened next as he stays in character
grumbling and picking up his things as
other students walk by one faceless
extra slams her backpack into maguire's
head and catches a strap on his neck
this blooper is actually a prank
courtesy of director sam raimi he's the
guy with the backpack surprising maguire
and making him laugh
[Laughter]
while spider-man isn't as loaded as
batman or powerful as superman he does
have one big thing in common with them
he's an orphan those other guys were
raised by a butler and some kindly
farmers while spider-man grew into a
goofy and friendly team thanks to his
aunt may and uncle ben in a rapid fire
barrage of bloopers from the set of
spider-man homecoming ned played by
jacob batalan and peter tried to talk to
liz about the current team party scene
and peter mentions how parents sometimes
let their kids throw those parties that
bit of dialogue sends holland off the
rails he remembers that his character
doesn't exactly have biological parents
anymore they let you have parties you
know my parents are dead
a quiet heartfelt moment with the object
of your affection can make even the most
confident person into a tongue-tied mess
but hey sometimes deep thoughts and
feelings are better left instead right
that would make one spider-man 2 blooper
extremely realistic except toby maguire
isn't supposed to be so worthlessly
flammoxed in a cute romantic scene with
kiersten dunst who's playing mary jane
watson
to his credit he sells that mistake of
simply being overwhelmed by emotion but
then he realizes he's been silent for
way too long and that the jig is up
part of what makes spider-man such a
great character are the differences
between the bold superhero and his
mild-mannered alter ego spider-man is
peter parker of course but they're also
total opposites at least to the casual
observer for example spider-man glides
through the air with the greatest of
ease peter parker on the other hand is a
gangly and timid teen who's not quite
comfortable in his own skin in
spider-man homecoming the actor meant to
embody both peter and spider-man really
nailed peter parker's awkwardness tom
holland is almost too deep in character
the actor apparently tripped slipped and
stumbled quite a lot during the making
of the movie
maybe toby maguire feels uncomfortable
doing romantic scenes and action-heavy
superhero movies or maybe he doesn't
think the idea of introducing the comics
character gwen stacy is necessary for
the already overstuffed spider-man 3
which already had so many characters or
maybe the actor has just gone a little
stir crazy from playing spider-man in
three movies over five years whatever
the reason maguire can't seem to get
through filming close-up coverage on
what's supposed to be a simple exchange
in which gwen introduces herself to the
daily bugle photographer
hi peter hi
it the blonde wig
spider-man's web swinging is a special
effect achieved with some combination of
green screen cgi and actors suspended
from gravity-defying wires being
harnessed up like that is not exactly a
natural or comfortable state it takes a
lot of effort to get used to let alone
do a good job of acting in that
condition on the set of spider-man
homecoming tom holland couldn't seem to
get the hang of those dangling wires he
tries to turn his ability to navigate
the wires into a little dance in front
of his concerned co-star donald glover
whoa
hey are you all right man
in more wire-based shenanigans while
shooting a night scene for spider-man 3
toby maguire guides kirsten dunst down
to the safety of the ground while
notably not wearing a spidey suit dunst
has so much fun with the descent that
she lets out a couple of hoots which
seemingly causes maguire to forget his
line he improvises some silliness
instead
let's go get on my bike okay
in avengers infinity war when thanos
snaps half the universe to death
spider-man falls into the arms of his
mentor tony stark before turning to dust
i don't want to go i don't want to go
please
it's heartbreaking which means holland
probably wanted to keep things light and
bouncy when his character miraculously
returns an avengers endgame in fact the
actor literally bounces around the
rubble strewn set much to the pleasure
of downey jr who hugs the boy wonder for
just a little too long and even plants a
kiss on his cheek welcome back wall
crawler
seinfeld is undoubtedly one of the
greatest and most important tv comedies
of all time it's been off the air for
nearly 20 years but millions still watch
the reruns every day both in syndication
and online after nine seasons and 180
episodes plenty of onset silliness was
left on the cutting room floor here are
some of the funniest bloopers from the
set of seinfeld
not camera worthy nothing ever seems to
go right for unlucky loser george
costanza it would seem that some of that
bad luck rubbed off on actor jason
alexander at least in this blooper the
camera is supposed to follow him off
screen but it doesn't let me just check
excuse me
excuse me there's not a camera on me
throw about nothing the main characters
of seinfeld have been called a lot of
things selfish misanthropic
self-absorbed they all tend to feed off
of each other's nasty energy and that's
on display in this blooper george jerry
and elaine irritate george's hospital
roommate so george tosses a cup over the
petition or at least he tries to shut up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the way the scene crumbles whether or
not a cookie can be made into a paste
and forced into the mouth of an
unconscious man is a debate you'll only
find on seinfeld but the insanity was
too much for jerry and julia during this
tank cookie's not liquefied
they can't you guys could buy a cookie
kramer vs kramer michael richards is
just naturally funny the role of kramer
often required him to be funny with just
a look a gesture or just by plain
existing a challenge he executed a
little too well sometimes cracking up
his castmates and ruining the take
sorry i'm sorry but it's just that's so
funny okay we're rolling
can we do it
i don't know
no part for you
tv jerry seinfeld was a stand-up
comedian just like the real jerry
seinfeld and like his real-life
counterpart tv jerry sought out some
supplemental acting work on occasion but
the fictional seinfeld was not nearly as
successful as the real deal because i
can't act
i don't want the hum to help
bubbling over
season four is the bubble boy ranks
among the silliest and most memorable
seinfeld episodes in one scene jerry
can't stop himself from jumping the gun
and explaining what a bubble boy is
a bubble boy yes he lives in a bubble
what's a bubble boy
well i think jerry just explained that
he's a what he's a bubble boy
a bubble boy he lives in a bubble i'm
sorry
my father he's a bubble boy
a bubble boy yes he lives in a bubble
george wigs out after six seasons the
self-consciously bald george did
something about his problem and got
himself a toupee his newfound sense of
confidence draws new attention from the
opposite sex george somehow manages to
play it cool and then actor jason
alexander suffers a george costanza
moment
garoppolo goof
after countless dates girlfriends dumped
for petty reasons and otherwise failed
relationships it looked like jerry might
have finally found his match played by
janine garofalo in the seventh season
episode the invitations i tell you
we got tremendous you got a line yeah
i'm sorry
sorry i'm kissing jerry seinfeld i get
nervous
it's good luck to kiss a jew on passover
janine thinks it's good luck to kiss a
jew on passover
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]